here we go with three minute madness yep
yeah I don't really farewell with that
hello okay I score points with the the
Smith Maura but I still feel like I'm
always just a pawn down so i'm going
with something more conventional but it
usually leads to too aggressive play
anyway yeah the opens the Sian and it's
something that I really have to play by
ear yeah something like that is possible
but I don't really know if this
particular this particular thing is any
good I ESD five energy for looks
completely bonkers actually eyes got d5
I didn't do that so let's just push push
push yeah I think he might still have d
5 but if he hasn't played it till now he
probably hid probably pooped play it in
the near future I came I don't know you
really just no key this is I then yes
before but still I don't I don't really
think that's so dangerous know if it
takes there or what is his idea okay
Queen takes okay I'm out 495 I wonder
where we should i go here actually hum
chinks chinks to define I go to a 4
promise so let's go here might be 3a b4
b4 yeah 95 is I don't know i usually
want to go there but i think i might
need this just to to block blob stuff
yes is check but it's not really that
big of a deal i think 1 c 2 white also
has some ideas like Bishop to d4 and
then h5 just firing away mara said open
a door what is this check that guy I'm
living in Barcelona yeah probably nice
place to be in at least you get to get
to see good football on a regular basis
that's a pretty cool movie oddity that
he unleashed so Quint xb3 it's quite
quite quite something huh no takes pawn
takes rook e1 sure what can I do
probably have to do that it's got queen
bee three down this is a problem really
hmm you can just take on these three I
mean maybe it's got something else but
that's not bad at all um Bishop chixa
for as a problem really is um yes so Wow
time morning
take the tempo Quincy to rock f2 at
least something why he can take only
four but i don't know i had to play
something and I didn't have ages to
consider oops if I get in Bishop g4 it's
not that bad Mike Wiener rockets at
least I'm always okay is going for
Bishop to e6 I guess check yeah so here
mmhmm yeah Bishop c4 of course that's an
issue Bishop h atos has the retreat down
should avail yeah let's get going here
Queen g2 I've got Luke f2 it's not that
big of a deal it's very dangerous Bishop
f5 check and stuff
Queenie five would be nice if I get that
in check check folder for the defense
there check funny black for fits on time
when that on time okay I'm gaining some
rating here and that in that pool I
don't even know what my max rating there
is on my all-time highest in three
minute where is that actually three
minutes should look at my my stats not
the other guy three minutes and this is
actually my all-time high 2 340 okay
cool yeah you don't they never play that
really so it's no one no big surprise
mmm so game start mr. Yardbird here we
go what kind of opening can i play maybe
that's the Kings onion I know it's not
the most unconventional opening but well
I recently checkmated him quite a bit in
the Kings Indian so he's going for that
boring stuff that's not fair
just playing quickly here move first
think later yep yay 5i 1b5 I still can
play that still not a bad move for him
and possibly see for a5 b5 c4 that's
quite ok um hmm hmm talk about a double
attack Wow funny it's really just a
double attack look Andrew canty 7s
hanging hmm there's no way really to
trap something here amazing
but a rubbish with a rubbish situation
jim says some way now probably this is
this is the relatively best chance
trying to trying to irritate him somehow
but well he can't can just do this yeah
check the other one snide chief I was
coming immediately way this is still
rubbish but still I'm hanging on at
least for a moment Jim the only thing
that is helping he said I will exchange
down and the rooks well they don't have
many many many opportunities at the
moment so it's not i'm not losing him if
you mang I'm not losing instantly rope I
can just take it with a queen what a
rubbish game what a bad game but I came
I can get yeah I guess he's sick son it
doesn't okay but it's not really really
important
like rook a 4g five maybe yeah it's kind
of clutching at straws but some some
blunder I need some blunder yeah so not
really not really anything going on for
age five you need to he has to move the
naija it moves like that too and get me
get me back into this you probably
probably won't
still still really nothing happened and
still lost take CEA's got g3 maybe this
would then look at four or something
kind of hanging on at least time burn a
little bit somehow it continue with this
game is havin a thats that's mean that's
definitely definitely go down rook takes
Queen takes their ok check a check it's
with two queens laughs I was rubbish
gain cleaner for was night down nice
though this double double attack okay
this is boris slotnick here it's an
old-time hand lion Boris slotnick okay
so yeah come on let me close that
friggin window I think he actually has
written books on the French defense if
i'm not mistaken our books from the
1980s or 90s but so what is this i
wonder i wondered about this push and
when I had this opening some games ago
if fighting yes hey I can do that I know
it looks completely wrong but I get
United d2e foreign and I thought I
thought that this might compensate for
that small inconvenience of my king
traveling around
and the King still can um so can go to
see two months not completely bad really
he can avoid age five I don't believe it
seems like he does not want to play that
move okay I mean ik ik can play Queen
age three actually wow really okay let
that control Z form if I take their he's
got bishops eh you know we does not have
that but it looks like yeah that looks
like compensation I have to admit him if
I take it looks company compensation
Mary got so many weeks squares this is
so it looks more aggressive he's got age
seven hanging mean age seven hang so
let's see him can i push up to a tribe
or something yeah i have push of age
five I have to if I can somehow manage
to prevent him from canceling it would
be good here here we go can take their
and Bishop back that's not helping much
what about this OS is completely crazy
hmm it is a bit crazy but it's
interesting I saw that night xe5 as
possible it's just it's just I was
tempted that's not even doing that maybe
he's right maybe he's right not paying
attention to my crazy idea here
so yeah his fee is probably right he
still has the idea and now a tons of
stuff is hanging huh true true yeah
nothing the five was interesting but he
really did not he did not need to to do
it if he goes g5 now I take on f5 what's
the idea pawn takes pawn takes for have
six yeah all this is hanging by a thread
I'm getting stuff back now and age for
hang so i don't know if that was so
great so cheeks my can check with this
but jam it's not the greatest porn ever
996 mm-hmm you can still take them
that's no pin really and nowhere fork
really you can take on a form you
probably should do that or now or now
time morning so what is this so look
here for the checks on g8 oh really
okay that first I didn't expect that
move here that door check so check I can
just interpose of course yeah I have a
cute trick rook f7 Bishop f4 it was a
nice trick why didn't you fall for that
yeah no no I've got beehive checkmate as
a threat that's a cute little trick or
trick out of IDF b5 meet yeah this will
win the bishop but do have anything
better check don't think so check so
what's a check here or not don't know
let's take like that it's tricky check
check we forgot that he could do them
check that one sex one time you knew
wynia he had to give away the the piece
but it's not a clear win ha game but
start on a game let's go here credence
credence who is that I cannot play the
Latvian can I do that it looks
completely crazy I don't like if they if
they play good moves that's not fair
he's opening up the position to his
advantage okay so cheeky for a screen
age 5 what about this no night on take
here or here that's been very possible
take this okay that's maybe a playable
position I'm not getting check killed in
like five min channel maybe more like 20
okay um
I mean I was glad that I got something I
got Queens off so that I'm not
checkmated in short order but the
possession is still not good yeah and
some i still have weaknesses galore and
no clear idea how to develop a night to
ji-sun and 96 but not not much else to
do check night how that's a cute move 98
is an idea right I have to move this
night here cheeks no takes us not good
check there I mean you can check on the
aid of doing that still you can check me
check hmm you're just taking only five
is good there's this exact Oh
interesting I don't really get jacket
that haha that's tricky that's the trick
check I for Bishop she's so Wow
nice group b 7 good tons of stuff
hanging that looked like nicely played
game check and I'd have 60 time morning
hmm okay yes black resign that was not
working they played that nicely I mean
probably you can punish that even harder
but also it was certainly good enough
okay let's get going who is that no name
that Cuba yep ok Sicilian is always good
for some some dice action there how can
I do something crazy like this one for
g4 I think this is actually a move even
though it looks like a blunders g-form I
think that has been tried
not totally positive but but almost that
doesn't look too bad no no yeah that's a
good way to win games up okay that was a
Muslim of course white resins Queen d2
was my move but ok I'm really in like
quick modem and sometimes sometimes just
too quick nice donation there to the
Cuban Cubans rating I get played him
before i have a total crap score against
em have a point out of 70 we had
don't really remember any of that okay I
want a new game here and I have gained
started el camino no yeah I really have
to I really have to be a bit more
careful there with the moose this is
hard to come back from that's really
hard to come back from this is called
the fret opening actually I read that
once was kind of amazed that this
actually has a name yeah efore at five I
came poo hmm ok mmm that's the rubbish
it's really that bad even second-rate
continuations are good for for them for
wide and I mean you really really had
better moves ok i can't check here
actually why not
that's crazy night x f2 was also an idea
action input yeah that's good and it
should be played almost instantly for
better effect while it's a good him can
play whatever my Viking position is
still rather rather bad okay but c4
right why not see fun this is a good
good Bishop down a really good bishop
he's not he's not castling here quickly
wow so I have a clearly better position
after 10 moves with the threat opening
what does that tell you about chess you
can play any kind of rubbish in three
minutes yes here we go white resign yeah
that was every mood sorry for that game
because it was really mouse slip I
didn't want to make a fool out of him or
anything with this with this rubbish it
was just a mouse lip I wanted a five I
kind of mentally was prepared for a five
maybe that was why my mouse hand struck
with f1 started sorry not on Grand
Master okay who is that again incognito
k Kings gambit yeah that's a relatively
good line I've played that myself with
black this is one of the possible
replies and then Queenie form I think
but it's been a real long time since I
looked at this line a really long time
and I Bishop f5 that's probably okay for
black queen d 7
yeah Queen D sound no he really wants to
refute this mhm probably they're
probably with some reason ha now that's
difficult even to Papa hmm well that's
the Kings gambit for you after eight
moves you cannot defend your seat to
pawn cool how do i play can I I cannot
really make make a sacrifice all of it
okay yeah okay I know I would be one hmm
do I can I what about this and yeah this
end 95 I mean this is kind of
interesting maybe maybe this is still
interesting night a 195 threatening made
on yourself let that sits yeah at least
them at least some kind of core chaotic
still if he goes with 26 or something
like that after 26 is actually an
interesting move now last lagu 95 it can
take you forward have some hangs yeah
yeah i still play 95 here but the
problem is that now it's no made threat
he might have I don't know f6 or
whatever that was hmm night beehive SSSs
he this looks completely wrong might be
five water water weird weird game but
but I'm actually I mean queen s Quincy 7
is sorry when Queen seven would be a
major I mean yep just have to get rid of
his Queen down I really wonder if there
is some some way to do that 94 is
hanging I have a very weird idea
actually let's try that
he probably thinks that I'm completely
the dilemma stone drunk or something
time morning interesting yeah the good
one probably I have to stay on on that
down on that c7 square I maybe I should
have just taken up seven I don't know
ninety-five Bishop e3 I don't know about
that the real problem is he can take a
one now he doesn't okay well Knight g4
it's a check it's a check but I can
check here might why not I can take here
with tempo where's the Queen going
where's this Queen going now dad ever am
I trapping ask win I cannot believe it
you can go to a 6 can go to a 6 and then
I'm very close here very close 96 okay
yes given up his Queen here Quincy seven
no I wanted to go for that cheap trick I
couldn't resist but I don't think it was
was bad anyway checkmate wow this guy is
probably eating his head now boom wow
that was crazy completely crazy but it
is a he'll think you're pretty pretty
good end to this to this video it's not
called three minute madness without a
reason okay i hope you enjoyed that
thanks for watching